when i read your book and you were
talking about this is so
is so true any great artist
first learns from other people and you
said one of the greatest influences
was leon russell what was it you were
able to take away when you first heard
leon russell
he looked like this incredible alien
with these
long gray hair and this top hat and he
looked really spooky
and kind of you know intimidating when i
first heard him
play in like on the cocker he would play
like
i'm going down
[Music]
and it was that kind of everything i
loved about music
he molded into one style the gospel the
country
the soul the blues and he had it all it
was
um the guy in the band had it too the um
the
garth hudson the organ player in the
band um it was something
when i heard music from big pink and the
bad album and that changed the way i
wrote when i heard leon
that's the way i wanted to play all that
was
that was how that was he was the
pinnacle for me of what i wanted to be
as a piano player and so when i went to
the um
the jupiter in august of 1970 and the
second night i was in the middle of
burned down the mission going crazy
and i suddenly turned around and there
in the second row was this guy with a
long silver hair i'm going
oh [ __ ] this is leo it's liam russell
and i
i froze for a nanosecond and i just i
thought he's gonna
if he comes backstage afterwards he's
gonna tie me to a chair and say no this
is not how to play the [ __ ] piano
this is how to play piano
and i was terrified and he came
backstage and i was so
in awe of meeting him and he could not
have been sweeter but he came into the
dressing room and i said god
my voice was a bit hoarse tonight and he
said it's probably because you're
nervous and he said
you know you should always take a
spoonful of honey clear honey
a spoon two spoonfuls of cider vinegar
put a lot of hot water in it
gargle as long as you can and spit it
out and your voice will be okay
and i still do that to this very day
when i play estate